- Say hello to Dulé.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, we did.
- Did you watch The West Wing?
Were you a West Wing fan?
- Uh, I did not.
Actually I grew up without television.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- I grew up in the Bush in Australia, so,
I didn't have television
until I was 12 years old.
So it's not the thing for me to watch TV
- [Kelly] Gravitate towards, yeah.
- Yeah, it's kinda weird.
But I've seen your work. It's amazing.
- It's not weird, it's just different.
That's cool, what did you do?
- Nothing.
- Nothing? Yeah, it's like,
did you - obviously music?
- Yeah. We used to sit around
the piano and sing songs.
- Maybe that's why you're
so incredibly gifted.
Cuz you were like, nah,
I'm gonna invest in myself,
my talent, and my work
right in front of me.
- Well, it's just, it wasn't the thing.
You know, I just started to learn piano
and my dad was in the Army,
but he was a singer as well.
And so after dinner we'd
sit around the piano,
and we had a player
piano, which I have now.
After my mom died, I got it.
And we'd, you know, pump the little pedals
and we'd sing along.
It was all the show tunes, it
was pretty amazing actually.
- I love that.
Was there a real Jessie?
I know everybody's had to ask you this
but I don't know this.
Was there a real Jessie?
Like was there a girlfriend?
Was this a real story?
- No, I just made it up.
- [Kelly] No!
(Dulé laughs)
- No, I just made up.
No, it was a real story.
It was, I hadn't written for a while
and I was thinking maybe the music thing-
I'd been an actor for a while
but it wasn't really making
a lot of money back then.
I thought, maybe I better
look for something else
to support my future family.
So I thought that I'd become
a stained glass master.
- (gasps) Do you know how to do that?
- Which is sounding like
a great choice, right,
if you wanna support your family.
- Oh my God, I can't even
believe you said that.
Me and my sister are obsessed!
Do you actually know
how to do stained glass?
- Yeah.
- My sister and I are obsessed
with learning how to do stained
glass. This is a real thing.
- I can teach you.
- I-
- Well, no, forgotten that.
- I want to learn! Do a YouTube special.
Yeah, I'm like do
something, we wanna learn.
That's a random thing anyway.
- Totally random.
And I'd been to all these amazing
churches around the world,
you know, I'd seen all these-
- They're beautiful.
- And I thought - what's that?
- It's beautiful.
- Yeah. But I thought,
how hard could it be?
It's already glass, only colored.
(Kelly laughs)
- They've been doing this for
years. How hard could it be?
- It was a big deal.
- These artists and (laughs)
- So take our little glass
cutter and my soldering iron
and I started going to stained glass class
with the thought of
supporting my future family
as a stained glass master, which...
thank God that didn't work out.
- It didn't pan out? It didn't pan out.
- So and there was this girl,
it was this burning hot girl.
And it was just like,
oh my God, I just, I,
and of course she had a boyfriend.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she wanted nothing to do with me.
And I would try and, you know,
I was never really good
with chat with girls,
which is one of the reasons
I picked the guitar up.
It's 'cuz I was hoping they'd come to me
- (laughs) This is how
I shall communicate.
- [Rick] Instead of me
going to them, you know.
- It was a good idea.
- I mean, you can never
go wrong with the guitar.
- Yeah.
- I mean, it's a guitar.
- I used to carry an empty
case before I learned to play.
(everyone laughing)
- You're like Joey from "Friends"
leaning on the Ferrari or
whatever. That's amazing.
- Hi honey, how are you?
No, I was never that guy really.
I was very shy and I'd say stuff like,
"Hey, you look really nice today.
You know, are they Jordache
jeans? They're awesome."
(Kelly laughs)
And cause it was the '80s.
- Oh my God I love you so much!
I love it.
So what were your like '80s jams?
What were you jamming to in the '80s?
- Well, you know, you can't
be a child of the '80s
and not love Michael Jackson.
- Oh yes, absolutely. Prince.
- [Dulé] Yes.
- Yeah.
- Prince and all that.
- But I'm from a town
who is of a boyhood home
of a great rocker.
And you might know this person
if I sing this song to you.
- [Kelly] Okay, go.
- Shot through the heart.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- And you're to blame!
Yes. Jon Bon Jovi's from my hometown.
- Okay.
- I actually went to middle school
with his younger brother Matt.
- [Kelly] That's so small world!
- Yeah. Yep! Well, speaking
of the '80s too,
do you remember when MTV gave
away Bon Jovi's house on MTV?
Anybody? Anybody? Nobody? Just me?
- Do you remember when
MTV played music videos?
- It was at that same time.
It was at that same time!
- Do y'all remember that?
- I don't watch TV.
- I- well, if you watched,
you wouldn't see music videos.
I was like, why do y'all
call this MTV anymore anyway?
It was just weird.
But no, I don't remember that.
- Yeah. But, MTV came to my
little town in New Jersey.
It was a huge thing
cuz they were coming to
give away Bon Jovi's house.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And they gave away his house
and that's when Matt moved away.
- Maybe that's when they started.
Maybe that's when they
started giving away houses
and stopped playing music videos.
- See what I'm saying.
- Anyway, you've got a
big tour this summer.
So are you excited?
I know every musician's pretty pumped
about getting back out there right?
- [Rick] Hm.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, very excited.
We're going out with Men
at Work and John Waite.
- Yeah!
- Yeah, Men at Work haven't
been out in a long time,
so it's gonna be, and
they're both great guys.
I love both Colin and
John and amazing voices.
And it's gonna be, you
know, wall to wall hits,
it's gonna be a great show.
- I was gonna say.
- And we're all, you know, I'm
an Aussie, Colin's an Aussie.
Well, he's Scottish, but
he grew up in Australia.
- Yeah.
- And John Waite got one of my, you know,
top 10 voices of all time,
rock voices, just incredible
So it's gonna be a great show.
And they're great guys,
it's gonna be a great hang.
And so we're all looking forward to it.
- Are y'all ever gonna,
cuz this is my favorite
thing that people do
when they all get on stage
and you all do something together.
Are you gonna do something together?
- Yeah, yeah, we will.
We haven't worked it out
yet, but it's, we all-
- [Kelly] Work that out for all of us.
- Yes ma'am.
- Yeah, yeah, okay.
I command it.
Well, tickets for Rick's
2022 tour with Men at Work
and John Waite are on sale now.
But for everybody in our
audience, it's your lucky day.
'Cuz you're all getting tickets
to Rick's show here in LA!
(audience cheers)
You are going too! We're going too.